she defied the odds to become a star in
global football but nadia nadim hopes
she'd be the only one that would have to
do that
the afghanistan she'd left behind was
changing her father's killers had been
ousted and girls could try and mimic her
moves on the football pitch
but last month
all that changed
it's been heartbreaking to watch what's
happening in afghanistan right now
just because i felt we were over that
stage i was like in the you know back
in the history and it would not repeat
itself and i know what that means for
for the future of the country
what it means for the
development
of
of the country what it means for the
women and the girls
after her father's death nadia and her
family fled first to pakistan and then
to europe she made denmark's national
team and last season as league our
champion with paris saint-germain she
perhaps gave thousands of young afghan
girls the belief they too
could rise to the top
how do you feel about young girls who
would have watched you playing football
and have dreams of playing football
of their own what would you say to them
now
that's a hard one i don't know what to
say to them because i know they don't
they're not going to have the
opportunity to do so but i i want to say
that people should try to keep their
hopes up
even though that it really really looks
like a
dark situation
many people are saying the taliban have
changed do you believe they've changed
no i don't think so i think um
uh
they're the wolves that are you know uh
disguised themselves and she's right now
and then the true call is going to come
true my dad was
killed by the taliban
so i know what they stand for and what
their values are
today the country is once again
controlled by the group that killed her
father a devastating reality for nadia i
think there's a lot of similarities i
think right now because it's a
transition
and so they're kind of
i still feel like low-key holding them
back but if you see what's happening in
the airports and people trying to hang
on planes and falling out of skies
no one would react that way if
if you were not scared
nadia still remembers the fear that
drove her from her childhood home chaos
and horror just like today she says and
the feeling of being powerless
sadia chowdhury sky news